Russia is calling on civilians in the
Hassan region to leave as Ukrainian
forces gain ground in the Southeast
every day strikes to the cities of the
Curson region they deal serious damage
first and foremost to the people I'm
asking the leadership of Russia to help
organize an evacuation
all right for more on this Charles
Stratford joins me from crivi RE in
eastern Ukraine Charles it seems
Russians are taking very seriously the
possibility that ukrainians may retake
her son in the coming days or weeks
that's right certainly according to the
Russian installed official inside
kirison as you heard that sound bite
there he uh building on that he said
that he suggests that all people in his
words who want to avoid missile strikes
from the ukrainians should take their
children and leave the city it's very
difficult indeed to verify
solid information coming from inside
occupied kerson as you can imagine the
ukrainians here very nervous about
giving press access close to the front
lines what we do know though is that in
recent weeks the ukrainians have indeed
recaptured a vast amount of territory
most especially on the West Bank heading
north down towards the city of kerasan
cares on a huge strategic importance
basically the Gateway Regional Capital
to Northern Crimea and the base from
which Russian forces were launching
their offensive were pushed trying to
push up to capture all of kerasan kersan
region of course one of the four regions
that Russia is claiming to to have
annexed or wanting to Annex we know that
there are thousands of civilians inside
that City we were in that area
relatively close to it yesterday a lot
of as you can imagine Ukrainian military
in that area we saw tanks we saw
helicopter gunships Ukrainian forces dug
in in and around the fields we spoke to
civilians in that area
areas of land that have been recaptured
in recent weeks they're very nervous
about a potential Push by the Russians
again to recapture territory that they
have lost the big fear is is that
obviously as the ukrainians continue
this push South towards Gerson and every
day they claim to have recaptured
another settlement according to one
Ukrainian official here he's saying that
around 75 settlements have been
recaptured from Russians in the last few
weeks but yeah we we also know that
there are a lot of Russian soldiers
inside it cares on it's understood that
many of them are special forces there's
a lot of Russian military equipment in
there and they we understand are going
to find it very difficult to escape
quickly if there was to be a push by
Ukrainian forces on kirison because most
of the bridges have either been
destroyed or partially destroyed so of
course that has huge implications for
the civilians there but let's bear in
mind what would an evacuation look like
we know that a lot of the people a lot
of the civilians in kerson frankly do
not want to be part of Russia they would
be very reluctant to be evacuated to the
Russian side
would they prefer to have potentially an
evacuation Corridor to the Ukrainian
side is that a feasible option could
that happen would the Russians allow it
there's a lot of unanswered questions at
this stage that seems highly doubtful
but yeah of great concern now big
worries for thousands of civilians
inside kerosome but as I say very
difficult indeed to really verify it
solidly verify exactly what's going on
no absolutely you're doing and our teams
on the ground doing their best to verify
the information that they can Charles
Stratford reporting live from Eastern
Ukraine appreciate it